oh they don't want to know joining us
now White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders Sarah just your general reaction
all of this first and you're being
attacked today also look I think that
the White House is in a great position
and what we've been saying for the last
two-and-a-half years is finally I think
totally been vindicated the president
it's completely exonerated no collusion
no obstruction I find it absolutely
outrageous that people like Jake Tapper
you showed a clip a few minutes ago of
him saying I can't believe bar has said
no collusion so many times when they
have been saying that there was
collusion every single day all day for
the last two-and-a-half years it is
outrageous the way that the media and
Democrats have behaved and frankly the
meltdown that we saw unfold on TV today
is truly astonishing but it's a great
day in America not just because it's a
great day for the president but it's a
good thing when they can say that not
just the president not just his campaign
but no American was involved in
colluding with a foreign government and
it's a sad day in America when Democrats
and members of the liberal media are sad
that it didn't happen to me that's the
most mind-blowing thing of this that
they would actually want someone from
their own country to have worked with a
foreign government to take down the
president and interfere with the
election the sad truth is is the one
that we've known all along President
Trump is president because he had a
better message a better vision and he
simply outlets write up a lot of he beat
Hillary Clinton fair and square they
were spying on his campaign the Attorney
General mentioned it they freaked out
but it's true they also used the dirty
dossier to get in the back door through
quarter-page but then you had Stefan
halper working on behalf of the deep
state and going after Papadopoulos and
Carter page and Sam Clovis let me ask
you so the media is attacking you today
because I guess in the testimony you
gave you had said you're FBI
a lot of the FBI people you know or well
I can tell you let me put it this way
every FBI rank-and-file guy the 99.9% I
know have all thanked me
because their hurt their reputation
forcement agency in the world
just like our intelligence community
same thing the premier intelligence
community in the world they were hurt by
a few at the top and they're angry about
it and you said that but explained
absolutely look I acknowledged that I
had a slip of the tongue when I used the
word countless but it's not untrue and
certainly you just echoed exactly the
sentiment and the point that I was
making is that a number of both current
and former FBI agents agreed with the
president James Comey was a disgraced
leaker who tried to politicize and
undermine the very agency he was
supposed to run firing James Comey
remains one of the best decisions that
the president made the only problem is
he could have done it sooner and maybe
it would have been a better thing but it
wasn't absolutely the right decision and
every day since it was proven that he
was right all along I got a run he could
be fired for any reason and no reason at
all
and as almost all right Sarah thank you